yeah he's got to sleep items good
evening members it's almost getting on
half seven so will Mike to start their
tracking members the on he hit though
i'll start by just reading at the
emergency evacuation announcement please
note that means it will be audio
recorded should we be required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the room by the door to the fire
escape staircase please help both hammer
idle sequence the stairs are wet or
slippery if anyone is enabled to the
stairs but they please allow others to
exit the room before they go to the fire
escape door where they can then be given
assistance I'm simply importantly in the
car pop public car park at the side of
the Civic sweet please do not yield
didn't do not delay your evacuation to
collect any bellowing please do not
return to the building and some given
tradition to do so by council staff
fight from one alleged that apologies
for absence hopefully we received
anything because Nick Cooper is
intending to arrive but you might be
doing you coming from pain thank you
English know any knob members attending
there are none and item three minutes of
the meeting harrogate with November 26
degrees have been so glad to be hopeful
everyone's had a chance to have review
our members happy from instyle note ruin
it thank you very much
any declarations of interest at all no
okay thank you very much I 25 treasury
management 2016-17 mid-year review
welcome Rob Manning this evening thank
you for coming members will have all had
the reports circulated to them and had
an opportunity to have a look at that
perhaps rock we can start if you could
just talk us through it yep just give us
a look give a verbal I think only get
one chance read it in the moment with
questions remember we'll have a quiz yep
setting up thank you good evening
everyone so the treasury management
paper you have in front of you so
basically there is no change to the
treasury and investment management
policy that was agreed back in april i
think there's no specific change there
we've highlighted or we've reconfirmed
the capita color coding that we use to
help band our investments there is no
change there it's just to make sure i
von't aware of them and tweet we just
keep them forefront of everyone's mind
and the total capital expenditure of the
of the council has increased from 474
thousand to nine hundred and twenty
seven thousand this year so where we had
a budget reason 474 thousand and the
main difference being is where we
carried forward works from 2015-16 into
this year and that most does the depo
about 320 k and so what that means is we
had funding for it last year which
they've got the same funding for dishes
there's no real impact it's just the
year where the work actually occurs so
just so so when you see that done before
I we haven't got an approved extra work
at the moment as because our DC doesn't
borrow any money we don't encourage
something called the MRP the minimum
revenue provisionally sorry for the
typical and currently at the moment that
the plan is and what we can see and what
is approved that we won't continue to
borrow yet so therefore we run
concurrent MRP just say let you know
please basically the we have to
recognize an element of the debt every
year so what we could do is just sit
with the debt on our balance sheet for
the next 50 years because we get a nice
right from the government but what the
MRP does it stops us doing that and we
have to sort of recognize a bit of it
every year so but as the moment because
we don't have any borrowing therefore we
don't need to recognize that but it is a
budget impact if we ever do so something
to be aware of in the future though if
we do wish to consider some further
capital investment that is more than we
have either in our own funds or through
grant then we might have to borrow and
at that point if we do borrow we would
have to recognize the amount pieces just
a revenue budget implication we just
must be aware of so and finally sort of
said towards the end of the report
economic growth has has faulted
considerably in the UK and that's any
news to anyone the recent autumn
statements will prove that the fact that
the deficit ner is not expected to be
closed until at least twenty well at
least after 2020 are the next parliament
anyway and an effective there is so much
uncertainty at the moment no one's
willing to take event and where it's
actually going to end up so in the
meantime this year we know that the base
rates have fallen from about 0.5% 2.25
percent and there is a risk that could
drop and down again to nearly the one
nor point one percent what that's meant
is that what the investments we do make
an berra mind the investments we make
are what we call Saul short-term
deposits basically so between three and
six months deposits with banks pretty
much are now in the region of sort of
point one to point two five percent in
terms of the returns we're not making a
great amount of money but clearly we're
not taking any oh we're taking some risk
but hardly any risk because that's the
new investments we've chosen to stick
with so what that's going to mean is and
it's the same sort of as we forecast so
far throughout the year and we will only
generate around 30,000 pounds worth of
interest this year on our balances we'd
originally budgeted close to some 85,000
pounds
and we'd expected the interest rates to
a sort of leveled off an attitude
increased by now obviously the impact it
breaks it and the uncertainty as I've
said before just really it just means
the mountain interest rates are going to
stay considerably low for the rest of
the year so I can't see that 30,000
pound going anywhere but the best it
will stay the same if not it might get
worse so that's that that's the crux of
the reports and obviously now come
question how many members questions okay
stop with counsel hook quite first
please and interesting programs watch it
down again is this weekend and they
Michael taught silicon stars give Cesar
new on on the number of different issues
in relations the autumn statement he
said that there's one thing we can
pretty much guarantee that the forecast
will be wrong but we don't know in which
direction it would be wrong so I know
that's obviously very difficult for
someone like you to sort of might try to
take into consideration but you say
around is there anything that you know
these their parameters that you try to
work with any on rather than Toronto so
fly and focus on on specific guide or do
you look at other other forecasts as
well well to us we get a lot of our
information from casa so we get a lot of
treasury advice from captain we also use
the treasure management team or the
chief accountancy team at Essex County
Council as well and talk to them quite
regularly and to be honest the obviously
the main impact for us of mum is the
interest rate because we choose not to
invest in a risky or highly risky sort
of
instruments should I say actually we are
basically linked to interest rate so for
us at the moment what we've tried not to
do in the in the future forecast is try
to over egg that and say we're really
going to you know it or going to bounce
back and if I'd be happier with them and
we're going to make multiple hundreds of
thousands out of this because we just
want so unless we physically change the
treasure treasury management strategy
which to take on more risk then actually
I think what we're going to be doing
this flap a sort of moving around the
edges we won't be getting into big big
changes anyway so the worst thing I can
see is actually if we went to a null
point once and interest rate as if we
then moved into pendency something like
a negative interest rate on our ordinary
bank deposits where we have to actually
paid money to keep that money in the
bank versus versus receiving income that
would be my biggest fear of alignment
time follow up on the hello the V the
federal reserve was looking to increase
rights in America and the thing that
might have on on us over here was it was
it might mean that we could be looking
at a rate rise sometime in the future
yeah he said there any analysis to to
say that the Federal Reserve will be
increasing rates near future it's not so
I've looked at to be fair and we have
got an interest rate forecast from from
Captain s if that's in the report and we
can see that you know they expect the
interest rate to double by sep tember 17
and in to increase finally by March 18
to 1.25 percent now that would get us
back to hopefully you know very well a
hundred thousand pounds of income target
on our existing investments I suppose
the likely good but the bottom rocker
said is the uncertainty I'm pretty sure
no one can tell us but these numbers are
going to probably changed since I've
receive them as well sir okay
thank you vent surrounds your question
counsel feel quite yeah counselor mr.
Mason thank you I've good there are some
questions I've got to ask mr. Manning
we've got to be you know formal haven't
we and because if I don't then it may be
seen that we didn't contemplate knowing
the answer these questions the first
question is about 3.5 and in particular
you declare three projects where there
is a probability i would probably
suggest to use of a be borrowing
requirement i know that you'd not put
any any figures in for the boring
requirement for each and i can probably
understand maybe the reasons for doing
that having said that this committee has
to consider lowering as part of its
remit of looking at the general finance
is something of the council because
anything we borrow ends up in a capital
account so that explains why we would do
but i really haven't got a feel for what
those borings not identify them to a
particular project because i understand
the issues in doing here but what would
be the as I guess the cash flow forecast
for next year the year after the year
after 44 borrowings new borrowing isn't
Oakland do you have those figures we'd
unfortunately because still so early on
with some of these projects we really
don't know the answer is we don't know
even that we have to borrow at the
moment it will depends on things like a
new homes bonus that we receive how much
we settle in our fighting dishes budget
in the mtrs we put aside from our
revenue budgets into reserves or see the
plan is try and use as much of your own
reserve as you can
for you negate your borrowing costs and
it's only at that point we'll be able to
say both sides and formula to say
actually what do we think we're going to
spend on a cash flow versus where do we
think we're going to fund it from at the
moment it would be it could range yeah I
just don't know okay time follow up on
that Kevin I have another question after
that i'm ok so do we have any
back-of-the-envelope risk I guess
profiles on the hello I'm asking you
something that would go with a formal
report therefore would have been to do
by this I assess I've thrown from
business cases you haven't even got
anything and I'm trying to use the term
to the back of an envelope that might
give us anything now I'm sorry not the
moment ok I was bound to ask the
question otherwise the public record
will show that this committee was not
interested in asking we all good
questions about how much we might be
boring ok this place is where we now I'm
afraid you go to another subject and I
was very interested in paragraph 3.20
yep on page five point six and I wasn't
so much interested in the first sentence
but it was very interested in the second
sentence and I will read it just idly
ketchup a review of the council's
investment strategy will be undertaken
in the new year new tier no you new
generation look at her tears yeah it did
ok and strategy considered the sixth and
maximize the returns on investment and
into the recommendation we're talking
about identifying the issues on this
topic prefer the consideration
discussion by the committee and I assume
the committee means review in Italy ok
so to kind of kick that off and
understand the scope of that obviously
you explain to us that maximizing the
returns on investment wasn't something
that had a very great price
so the same time but I've got a sentence
that says we're going to do that then I
guess this committee is going to do it
so I'm afraid it gives me a cause for
concern absolutely the cause for concern
is referring to what we discussed as a
proposal in February 2016 there was a
great deal of discussion analysis about
and you raised it earlier about
restating around market priced
investments can I have an absolute
assurance that this strategy tooken to
to seek to maximize the return
investment it will not include such a
proposal in future so Lance they're
integrating so first answer is with it
the I think it's the sit for guidance on
a investment strategy policy has to be
has to be in three stages first stages
if your investment must be secure so you
have to consider security first
absolutely number one after that you
don't have to factor in the liquidity so
how quickly how ready is your money how
quickly can you turn it back into cash
to go and spend it again and then
finally you should think about the yield
the relative investment now what what
paragraph three point two actually means
is how do we maximize the returns on the
investments within the constraints of
our existing treasury management
strategy I wasn't proposing to go and
try and do anything more radical then
the limits we've already imposed on
ourselves the the products which and
investments we've already decided we
would go for it's about how do we just
maximize what we can already so how do
we go and look for the best rates with
the various banks heaven we look at the
various six monthly trackers the various
money market funds things about the
safer investments that we have chosen to
use now I'm not going to say absolutely
in the future we won't go to more risky
higher return type products because
actually in in a year's time two years
time we may it may be the right thing to
do but we certainly cannot do it outside
of this group and it will only be for
through and improved treasury management
strategy that
that caveat that 3.2 it's not supposed
to be another way of getting there in if
we are going to talk about dedicated
products for me we have to list them out
the treasury management strategy and
we'll discuss them so for me at the
moment this is not intending to try and
get that through the back door if that's
if that is good intentions no i was just
seeking to ensure there's absolute
clarity on the issue and because as you
know and then we're not allowed to
attribute anything to an individual in
an away day but of course we can refer
to it out of ideas gathering there was a
consideration given to that and a
proposal made for that and obviously
unbound you know to to ask the question
does that have any sort of wings and
clearly it doesn't you did talk about we
might reconsider that in the future and
of course i can accept that but from my
point of view in the experience I've had
and it's been in Treasury and as in
management and markets then i would say
i find it awfully difficult to see a set
of circumstances where we would be very
assured that a market value of an
investment in this market related an
interest bearing which stands still for
a long period of time because you very
mind that if the price of a market
interest instrument falls that that then
stops you getting your money back in
terms of the nominal amount you invested
it also infers that the yields are going
up in the interest rate market if that's
the case then had we invested in them
it's not about waiting for the money
back it's also about suffering a much
lower interest rate he'll and we would
have done if we hadn't done it in the
first place so i find it terribly
difficult to contemplate a sack
circumstances where those fundamentals
wouldn't apply because there is real
risk in that
if i may just follow up son i think what
i was also well i was also alluding to
wasn't necessarily the tradable markets
but also things like potentially
property funds we could look at other
you know non-tradable type of products
which may be consideration in the future
I mean it's and all Rome yeah I mean
that it's our consideration but I think
it's the right discussion to have at the
right time but at the moment certainly
totally agree ok yeah obviously we've
seen what's happened to the property
market and property equities and indeed
to sort of property investments we might
have thought thought about thinking
about and look this time last year but
the fundamentals of those again around
like to change in the short term
particularly around high-yield
investments and you know that's an
interesting one because that's something
that also should should test the minds
of of the investment ball around
particular declaration of a of a project
in send projects and south straight for
the same reason Sharon it sounds to me
as if we've been given we've been given
the sort of assurances that I think we
need in the difficult circumstances well
the council finds yourself in it is it's
a it's a fact and also you know the
circumstances of the country which we
have to acknowledge as we go along thank
you thank you very much yes that's
Tanner more countries
so Rob Maness is anything is is there I
know we deal with Triple A or triple
plus or where it is investments and what
have you but have we looked at
alternatives just as I escaped just to
look at st. Double A or something like
that which every is below that standard
what we are looking at and if there's
anything that we could sort of not
foresee obviously but perhaps with their
with a little bit finds out what's going
on if we could have perhaps moved a
little bit to one side just fractionally
not totally but freshly could we have
made a better so the honest answer is so
when I last presented and the times I he
keeps februari we didn't spare creating
a dummy portfolio between we're going to
go away so that hasn't gone away we've
been sort of working on that in the
background but the honest answer is we
took to capture our treasury management
strategy our partners should we say and
they advised us there wouldn't be a
strategy at the moment that they could
say would be worth us going after they
said that the risk profile was just too
big so I thought it'd be bit silly to
come back and present a dummy portfolio
we would never have gone there anyway so
yes we do do that quite often we do
every running in the background but to
be fair the risk profile currently is
just so great yeah it would have shown
may be some good returns but it's just
something we would reside with them
they're like I said there be for us is
security in liquidity it's nice to get
money at the end of it of course it is
but its back even our money safe so do
you think that we're holding ourselves
really just by doing that some people
doing that we're holding themselves up
and the lower end if you like a market
rather than I know we've got to take it
is taking a risk that's the point I be
honest with very little what we're going
at this moment in time should we be
invested in other schemes for a longer
period yet I think in terms of what I've
no it's not hands up haven't done a huge
amount with other areas but I know one
of the bigger areas in Essex that do
make a decent return on their money
should i say his brain tree and i
understand that they actually invested
in there was called the ccla which was
the property fund that's run by the
Church of England now lots of
councillors have done that we talked
about it in a la one of them now is we
meeting to e were here and it said we
could turn I think it was something like
between seven and twelve percent or
something like that it's got over the
last you know sort of ten years but the
problem is it's it tied up in something
like property he's tied up the liquidity
on it is rubbish you know you basically
they've got a seller property could take
six months to a year to get our money
out and talking quite long term
investment and as we said the property
market is so fluctuate another noise for
shelter breaks it and the u.s.
protections it was something we decided
at the times just not worth the risk and
I still say the same at the moment the
CCL a specifically or a property fund of
that nature at the moment I just can't
see it being worth while so that's the
only area we would get that we could
potentially think about in terms of a
specific product so the other way we
need to think about is how else can we
invest our money better to try and
generate another returns or maybe
through an investor side project so a
lot of work we I do it County on my
other hat is how do we invest in
services to actually try and reduce
demand in the future so it's not a
specific gonna invest money in a you
know in a financial instrument or a
capital piece of work but how to invest
in our services so therefore in the
future we save money that's still a
return on investment as such but it's
not a specific financial instrument you
view it's you're investing in the
community as well that's something where
we could think about it it wouldn't
necessarily be linked to this because
it's not specific treasury management
piece
all right thank you and council boy oh
thank you Joe go back to the minimum
revenue proved against Charles River Tom
prism mm from the traffic i shal carroty
around it is me or something maybe
overlooked in the past mm-hmm a copy of
an example thing you say if I'm right or
wrong with my assumptions things go well
wording it yeah if in the past with 40
say two million pounds to buy a refuge
vehicles yak is abhorrent only move
actually got have borrowed it yeah I we
sang that the two million pounds would
have been put through over a length on
now many areas not just the interest the
actual to mean can we borrow and go
through the revenue occurs that's right
over and how is that is there an ATT
sort of it over the life of the protocol
though the all of this all of the item
over the life of the asset whatever is
so we're talking about the rights you
know what a clarity you talk about the
boring i we talk about the borrowing all
the air so you purchased was it but so
they get double hit so you posted the
line and you pay for the interest costs
on something you're the interest yeah
but don't get we don't have a dsl to
appreciate the same way you guys who is
currently currently on step so innocent
your depreciating the asset and you'd
appreciate the interest right which is
the borrowing but if we're not in the
essay as well they're doing the exit
through the bottom right that's fine I
understand but it's the difference
between public and private account
that's wanted to character yet
understanding it works outside yet
there's no and the reason being it's
just so explain what that means is in
the past councils local authorities and
the NHS could have borrowed lots and
lots of money at what we call pwl be
right so government discounted rates one
two percent and they've already
basically stuck up their balance sheet
and forgotten all about it because as
long as they pay off the little little
bit being tripped every year that day
and that dell has built up over 50 60
years the government all of a sudden
synergies we've got quite a big debt
sitting there no one's ever pine alpha
because why would you you can one
percent interest why you should pack
forever and you keep refinancing it so
just stop that I said any debt that you
now raising the future
you have to account for the whole thing
around portion of it so if it was a
building you'd say 50 years so and you
just and it's the same as depreciation
but counting we don't account for
depreciation so base its to stop you
over borings to make you think about
boring and try and use your own funds
that's in effect with it's all okay
thank you that's right yeah counselor
mrs. Mason and thank you Jim I'm
listening with interest and I think
we've heard an awful lot and that had
we've had a lot of clarification on the
subject under discussion what concerns
me slightly is that the two
recommendations that we have don't quite
mirror the conversation that we've had
and if you could just at this point make
a suggestion and then it's up to you
whether you want to alter that or not
for the chair that 5.11 we recommend
that the full council note the contents
of the treasury management mid-year
report rather than recommend it because
obviously i think we are recommending
anything in particular other than we've
liked that bloated and bear in mind the
concerns that are being raised over
three point turn and the clarification
that we've received and the assurance of
the impatient just to make that clearer
perhaps that items hope we can expand on
that to say that the recommendation is
to identify any issues on this topic for
Cup further consideration of discussion
by the review committee within the
constraints of our current treasury
management strategy as you just too so
that so there's no at the moment there's
a slight conflict between the intention
the report and the letter of the report
I think if we just slightly alter the
wording on that recommendation that
would clarify that point if everyone is
happy with valid you mine is producing
my B's man repeating it totally can do
want repeating onto all right okay if I
the review committee because it doesn't
say what you're committing within the
constraints of our current treasury
management strategy zeljko here broke
ass on yes absolutely members are all
happy with as well yes okay thank you
mr. Chen thank you oh I just got a
couple of questions which are really
about the report was before was just
probably for me to view the other
counselors that I'm failing you wish to
the review committee selling oh just
application you mentioned the report
that the authority is invested in the
financial institutions that the
authority is investing with ya I'll
monitored on a regular basis yeah in
longely we start going to monitor that
is it rdc or is it capita or but it's a
bit of both mostly it's capita and then
we have a monthly call with capita and
they advise us of any changes to where
we've got institutions that have moved
between the various bandings and we also
have a quite regular call with Essex
County Council as well and they just
give us a heads up of whether the major
movements have been as well so Unser's
usually on a monthly basis every with no
home capital yeah absolutely what and to
be fair what they do is will they do
give us a and they don't just wait for
the monthly call if there's something
major happens they will let us know
pretty quickly to be fair okay and just
for the clarity as well just for the
mideast of this meeting the council's
risk appetite whatsoever it reminds lung
if that's what it's like to do them all
absolutely none thats just goes down
yeah okay do you think if I may I mean
if you think about the majority of where
our money seeds it's in banks that offer
three months terms six months terms it's
probably very similarly you would have
as a as an individual you know with what
you would see is your own
a 31-day account or something like that
there's nothing particularly more
complex than that here the other points
I just 10 looking back at the minutes
from fairies meeting and ankles meeting
you touched on one already tonight which
is dummy portfolios yep now obvious that
that it was there has been some change
of the guard service customer any
particularly cost of property investment
where are you happy with dummy more
photos on you've already said that.you
even further they're still on the
backbone oh yeah I'll still float it
around I mean we don't do keep them
going then don't say keep them going the
problem is we I sought to capture
several times on this and they said we
can advise you on a dummy portfolio but
actually what we would present you would
wouldn't be one that we would ever
actually present you anyway because
they're so risky we've almost got a
quite a void between where we are
compared to where they you know where
the next sort of stage of options would
be and actually what they're saying is
yet we could we can give you a range of
scenarios and you could monitor them but
actually what we would get from image
you wouldn't be very very useful at all
so I'm more than happy to come back
again and show some of that but I think
what you are saying you think in your
opinion you think it would be look
usable worthless but slightly pointless
or slightly better than the task of yeah
I think what it could also do is confuse
the matter because it may show in
certain cases there might be quite a
high return on certain things so what I
don't want is everyone think all right
we could make a big return because the
chance that we're not going to take that
sort of risk on in the first place it
almost becomes a bit of a hundred points
and among those eyes as well I noted
that there was talk of arranging
meetings with other districts of a
similar size to discuss their investment
or they're only open yet I understand
that that's not happened is that
something that is that an option week
worthwhile optional weekend I mean that
that was originally in the februari
meeting which was when we were
discussing the potentially the high-risk
sort of options and then when we came
back together I've belay
in April we decided actually wouldn't go
down that route IP honest I took up
myself to say we may not need to go and
talk to us but we certainly can I mean
it's not sorts of a week and we've got a
regular finance officers meeting I can
certainly ask a couple of guys to come
along to like say brain through I know
do fairly well they get a return of
about six hundred and seventy thousand a
year off a 25 million investment parts
they've got a bigger more money than us
and they do generate a you know two to
three percent return but they are taking
far more risk in terms of their property
portfolio so we can certainly get some
stats you think it would be worthwhile
somebody coming in from it just a brief
chat with us or not at the moment I'd
function I do what I would say if you
can leave it with me let me go and talk
to at least all of the other Essex
authorities get up get a spread week and
we want to sort of discuss about this
stuff anyway get a spread and if there's
anything in there that I think look
particularly useful that actually might
be something we'd want to consider that
might be a middle ground we haven't
thought of okay then I'll bring it back
how is that acceptable bother they just
bring someone in to sort of talk for the
sake of it again I'll tear I'll come
back tomorrow moving which I will do
quite a lot is my County hat they return
on their investment and run was running
a point nine percent nevermind they have
sometimes upwards of nearly 700 million
pounds to invest the most risky
investment bank have is with the ccla as
well so they they do not at the moment
not many people want to go further than
that though okay caps estonia voila
question Thank You chairman Diaz and
fruit from a meeting that we had the
golfer way down did we come up with any
ideas that we can put forward
then my helpless no we aren't so we did
ask everybody to get will contribute
something and what we could don't but
although we there are still song I know
anything yet another the ideas of which
looks about our leadership team last
week week for other late and then
there's a something due to come out to
all members hopefully before Christmas
it's not just after with all of the
ideas together and potentially a ranking
of where we could see some some
potential that we can then discuss
further that the next go later thank you
very much again council hook way hmm it
is something that some promising to
behead wife you're talking about
something he talked about a lot of
baggage about getting information from
within Essex I can understand you know
the reasoning behind there but is there
the possibility of looking a bit further
afield to see you know what maybe some
other councils are doing in other parts
of the country which might be looking
different from from what we might be
doing here yeah we can certainly do it
on I'll be honest I thought I don't know
you know go and talk to hundreds of
different councils just get similar
answer if I was certainly trying to up
so many things or civic but you had if
items in particular area or a counselor
well it's got to be something that there
is a comparable there's no group looking
at an authority which not a unitary
authority of that other it's not good at
it's not going to be much that you can
take out that but perhaps there are some
soul priorities which have a some quite
good comparisons
like may be of interest yeah concerning
look at echo yeah very much no members
of block any other questions I don't
believe that one signal isn't I have so
thank you very much for attending the
meeting I've already i remembers go back
to the report members happy to note that
before and with the amendments that
counselor mrs. Mason propose we do thank
you very much thank you move on to item
6 which is the key decision doctor
please I mean Wilson out today or
anybody happen but probably isn't even
half of the thing we have
hung up through the question a full
members got coffee now yeah yeah okay
are four feet would you rather ask
question before I refer to Paul just a
bum through them for each other for two
hundred and first Cody stop squishing it
is a comment yep Anika so those the
facility is that on this one 10 min 16
is skipped by two months already from
the last one and undies just up notice
that there was a quite awful skipping
some of these key decision documents
which does give me some concern so that
we're getting the last 14 10 16 was 32
November 16 for instance and then that's
this one there's others which were
earlier as well and i think one Bulow's
slipped a bit it may not have done i
think it has but there yes that was the
calming and concern africa expecting you
perhaps belay that officers officers
yeah and
the first two that has canceled my boy
will put it down broken on there before
the first one is slit from the 30th and
I've ever to the first January and the
second one is slipping faith a November
through the 3rd give the december i will
make offices aware that their slippage
has been knowing so you're not worry
buddy reason what about not keen on them
as mentioned how it came out today and I
am that chance to actually talk to the
officers involved sorry now counselor
mrs. my son I was just a thought if we
are getting sleepy delays perhaps we
could ask for the reason for any tonight
we just put into the report if just be
so that so that we know because I don't
think that the pool should have to ask
each time or look up and check but the
assistant director should know it's like
they're changing the date and they
should be able to give us some reason
why you're laughing that's good idea
perhaps we could get that in our members
how through that suggestion I mean in
the box with the dates just a simple
yeah or another box just yeah however
what we cannot see what we've however
it's done I don't lie but I would like
to say that one game so save us in
counting back through its only happen to
also cuz Thank You Man castletroy
perhaps just with the original going on
there sit yeah original day and razor we
get some of em gonna die young three or
four
like okay um yeah new one on there is
the bomb detector brands they contain 18
which is usually made on the
twenty-eighth of every to their local
level it's it's section moved I think
you always used to be bound about
Christmas December time it was always a
crush but I think there is a report that
we need to exec that has agreed that
they will move filling is not to the
budget process further on but that's why
um there's usually a group that sort out
those from all the parties of cancer
hook when you know in just just to
confirm I really cuz i've been on the
holders involved the better ones the two
occasions that I've been involved it's
always happened before Christmas so but
I thinking probably provided the
reasoning behind it is time much more
into the devotees process announcement
yeah yeah I think did they do a top size
for more fco and see image and say they
it's just the others and then can
actually move I think radisson selling
they have always been well said they've
got an agreement three-year agreement
the ranks have got to know their funding
and you've got to give me three months
notice and that's why there's always be
before december in case we weren't going
to fund further on down line to vm well
the applicants aware of the change of
the day because it might affect their
budgeting again arm uh no vendras been
liaising with the various groups and he
has she he asked for input from the
applications because obviously wraps and
say hey Leah a different based to the
other funding request that you get okay
Thank You counsel mr. Luscombe channel I
did indicate you before the meeting so
if I may I I know we're looking at key
decisions and we have those key
decisions listed but sometimes what
we're unaware of the other things the
review committee can actually do and
there is a very it was very interesting
meeting of the investment board on the
16th November and although the minutes
haven't been adopted and then it will be
adopted when there's another investment
board I just thought I'd draw attention
to something that we may not have
realized I'll just read the particular
single sentence he responds to a member
question relating to commercial
decisions taking taken by the investment
board officers advised that these would
still be subject to call in by the
review committee so just on at this
point of talking looking at key
decisions so also remind members the
kind of chair of talks that
decisions of the investable can still be
called in okay thank you very much
anybody else got any questions at all
because the decisions document and then
okay thank you very much leaving on to
item 7 which is the work plan and
everyone should talk about people you
need to copy they indicate some shelves
and okay Paul market is the medium okay
at next meeting will be third parties
software report and building control you
will notice home this update has been
added to the temporary one was requested
and century housing but actually agreed
that they're coming so the confirmed
that one for the definite are you on the
fourteenth of march you will notice
Citizens Advice Bureau as we have a
three-year agreement with them they
should be important to a committee about
what they're doing thurman and so of
slightly into their as
those sort of things casimir smokin Joe
there's a couple of things I I've been
fortunate with counsel I to have a
meeting with the Managing Directors a
day in the usual course of review and
there is going to be an interesting
report in January without doing in
control of which it will visit the the
issues that building control has been
has been encountering in all sorts of
ways with proposals for immediately
going forward but also there is the
opportunity for a project plan to be put
in place to consider other options for
delivering the service so gues talking
be aware it's not a straightforward
report it's going to be one where we can
influence how that is taken forward in
the future and the second one we're
looking forward to to April and this is
nothing that I'm revealing that hasn't
been we do already in the treasury
management report you'll notice that a
borrowing requirement was anticipate is
anticipated at no particular level to
fund capital in the fusion contract and
in particular claim at all and you'll
know that we've only this year taken
reports from the portfolio holder and
the officer responsible for our service
and I think we've got to be thoughtful
about what that's likely to be we we did
say to our officer that we had an
expectation that notice will be given in
respect of refurbishment of the wet area
and it seems that that might be
something there's going to come up and
we want to ask about with fusion I'm
going to suggestion that we did last
time I know we talked about April but
time moves on that we have to a
two-phase process of that report we have
a
we have our officer assistant director
responsible for the leisure contract
with the port fairy aura because first
because we may well wish to explore what
has happened since we last met and then
with fusion maybe to review what their
response delay is okay not very cryptic
just trying to suggest that there's a
great deal more to both of those then
then is that you might be evident to us
would you like to amend that is it
that's what happens otherwise I'm just
bearing in mind that we've got a lot of
new members that possibly haven't seen
the sights it might be useful to you to
visit the sites beforehand members upon
that useful you know General shall
handle okay the time you figure rounds
up yeah handy I'll take referring back
to the point in counselor mr. most
America girls for building control if
that was all schematic January think all
you check to see when in general their
beaches of 10 so we need it early
January it's kind of quality you should
get it between xmas community and by
year is when the gender should be
published typically from I'm seeing the
ad planning next week to discuss the
ring at all and what
system okay it should well be ready in
time I'm kinda [ __ ] is what I'm saying
okay thank you very much have any
members got any questions at all already
pointed out to raise no okay bats who's
elected to finish you that meat 17 you
in hey